- Panda Express to me is like
white people's Chinese food.
(Chinese folk music)
- This is so gross.
- Wow, this looks like a candle.
- It's like soggy on the inside.
(Chinese folk music)
- If you actually know
real Chinese chow mein,
you'd be like, "This is
American Chinese chow mein."
- Ew, it smells like stinky feet.
- It actually tastes pretty authentic.
- I think it's not that bad.
- Wow, you've never had
authentic Chinese food before.
- Yeah, this is judged.
- I'd rather eat this than the egg roll,
I'll put it that way.
- Low standards. (laughs)
- That's how I end up with her.
- He looks down at Panda Express,
but he eats McDonald's all the time.
I don't understand.
- Melanie likes it.
Do you want mine?
(laughs)
- Good job says my grandpa.
(Chinese folk music)
- If you blind folded me,
I'm eating plain rice.
- It kinda tastes like cardboard.
(Chinese folk music)
- It smells so bad.
- It smells like putrid.
- Wow. (laughs)
- It's really sour. (laughs)
- Yeah, I do not like that.
Nope, no.
- This reminds me of taking shots,
like the bad aftertaste.
- They don't like it.
(Chinese folk music)
- This is my dad's favorite.
Like if he were here, he would hate this.
- Oh it smells good.
- Actually it smells OK.
- This smells good, yeah.
- Really? I feel like it smells weird.
- I like this.
- Oh, it's really salty.
(Chinese folk music)
- Orange chicken is not real Chinese food.
My mom calls it the food
that fools Americans.
- Oh, no, no, no, I know what this is.
Burnt soy sauce.
- Not sure what that is, you know.
- This chicken is sad.
- He had to finish all his orange chicken.
He says it's so good.
- I can't imagine anyone
thinking that Panda's
actually Chinese food.
- But you know what my
dad used to always say
is that you can't leave one
grain of rice on the plate.
- [Melanie] Yeah, that's
what my mom always said too,
so I don't like wasting food.
- Right, did you not get that
when you were younger too?
- Oh no, all the time.
- The grain of rice.